a pm keen to move onwards and upwards
this is final day with commonwealth
counterparts in rwanda fellow leaders
gathering together to discuss shared
priorities
but the personal priority for this
leader is to move on as he was finally
forced to admit mistakes he's made
prime minister you told me yesterday
people are bound to continue to beat you
up do you feel beaten at the moment no
no what i mean is that when you're the
the leader of a country in good times
and in bad you have to think about the
criticisms that you get politics is
about
allowing people to have the the
democratic safety valve of letting off
at governments but then such as in
in by-elections but then the job of a
leader is to say well
you know what is the criticism that
really matters here but the criticism
was about you sir that's right it was it
was about you that's right and i think
what people were hearing but you so you
do acknowledge that it's part you are
part of the problem well what i
certainly think is that if you look at
the by-elections uh people were
absolutely fed up about hearing about
things that i'd stuffed up uh endless
turn of stuff and what they wanted to
hear was well
yeah yeah but what is this guy
all that what is this guy doing and so i
want to talk about our plan to help
people with the cost of living
his cabinet too keen to talk about other
things do you agree with the prime
minister that he has stuffed up over
partygate
i 100
support the prime minister he's doing an
excellent job and we need to keep going
at this very difficult time
loyalists rallying around the prime
minister as he makes it crystal clear to
his opponents that he has absolutely no
intention of stepping aside for some
time yet but he also did give a little
bit of ground today admitting to me that
he had stuffed up and it had annoyed
voters but as he concludes this trip to
kugali he's not going to be going home
to face the music instead he's going on
to the g7 and nato where the war in
ukraine will dominate and the prime
minister wants to make the case for a
democracy under threat
the pm worried about world fatigue over
ukraine look uh i know that it's tough
it's tough in the uk i know that the
cost of food has has gone up the cost of
fuel everybody is looking at this too
many countries are looking at this thing
now and saying this is a european war
that is unnecessary it's an economic
problem
that we don't need
and so the pressure will grow
to try to encourage
coerce maybe the ukrainians to
a bad piece
and pressure to offset the economic
impact of the ukrainian conflict
our plan for a stronger economy
certainly includes responsible tax next
year they are coming in next month in
the form of big cuts
national insurance contributions
additional tax cuts next year we've
already put in cuts to cuts and fuel
duty additional tax cuts next year and
i know you want me to to go further but
then it's not me it's people that can't
pay their bills and so they need to do
what we can
a lot of red carpet royalty and moments
of respite for the pm in rwanda but as
this leg of his international tour comes
to a close things are certainly not
bright for this pm events of recent days
will be hard to put to bed beth rigby
sky news kigali in rwanda